avec tous ces indices est ce que tu
penses à une personne en particulier
si je te dis ludovic way est ce que ça
te vois quelque chose c'est possible tu
partagé beaucoup de choses avec lui il
est mort de rire
regarde
ludovic
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors avec moins de temps que je n'ai
pas vu non je te suis face au ca ce qui
se fait non je ne suis pas c'est pas du
tout
au début on avait une photo de vacances
de vous aimer arrêté sans déconner non
non non mais tu connais ludovic non bien
sûr que non ludovic si et quand par
exemple bas en 2003 quand j'ai quand
j'étais avec toi sur le sur l'europe
venait de dormir à la maison à la rue de
la roquette sûrement clic-clac non non
tout est faux pour pas rentrer je crois
que vous est ce que vous connaissez
cette personne n'a envie sûr que non
quoi vous ne connaissez pas c'est un ex
c'est quoi oui bah non mais ça faisait
appel non mais sans déconner je me
franck vraiment aucun rapport non
vraiment non alors il est venu me dire
pendant la pub on travaille ou galère le
bon mais qui peuvent amener au maine
[Rires]